hallo mein name ist khan
in den aktuellen zeiten kann man ja
nicht so richtig ins restaurant gehen
und alles das was wir hier im raum von
hamburg geliefert wird es einfach nur
krieg in englisch könnte track bedeutet
scheint auch das einzige was mir
generell der epoche sind diese nudeln
ich bin sogar so froh dass ich die
gekaufte die nur drei minuten lang im
wasser sein wissen und die es sich dann
immer zusammen mit diesem fertig pesto
das ist jetzt keine werbung für die
marke von der gleichen marke ist auf
jeden fall mit dementsprechend gedacht
du musst auf jeden fall wir kochen
er ist hat jetzt absolut gar nichts mit
kochen zu tun allerdings war ich im
supermarkt und hab mir gedacht mensch es
gibt so viele verschiedene farbige dosen
und getränke die absolut ungesund sind
ich möchte einfach mal alle zusammen
alle youtuber man irgendwie brief
untereinander hat playa streit mit rom
gespielt und konnte mit seinem eigenen
katar und ich ja ich war besser
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die weg gefunden als heißt das ding
stärkt das ist im mixer den ich damals
gekauft habe weil max bei mir im kopf
video drehen wollten der rollt neben das
football machen und seitdem habe ich den
original einmal benutzt brauchen wir
überhaupt mixa
[Musik]
zweiter sind jahre später so weit war
jetzt habe ich wirklich das ist auch
keine mussten
[Musik]
so damals perspektive frankreich
übrigens bitte nicht was ich hier an
habe ich habe heute morgen kleider schon
geguckt dass mir heute nicht mehr steve
jobs und steve jobs eine sache gut
konnte dann war es neue sachen und das
machen wir uns ein getränk nummer eins
noch joker marie weil ich hier fühl ich
da überhaupt ein
ich habe 2005 6 790 f12 getränkt habe
ich mir geholt
ich hab die kameraperspektive etwa
geändert ich glaube jetzt jetzt immer so
also als nächstes nehmen wir unsere coca
cola vanille
ich muss nicht mal dass so etwas
existiert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich weiss es nicht ist irgendwie hälfte
gut hälfte nicht gut und hälfte cola
coca cola ist auch drin den mann
sprechen mich sagen wenn wir jetzt was
ohne kohlensäure capri sun himbeere ich
bin gespannt ich kennt haben die sonne
nur aus dass auch kohlensäure drin so kp
es heißt jetzt cup in san ist verstehe
ich auch nicht singen als wollen auch
international man in amerika sagt bruch
unter ex sonnig ist das nächste produkt
was wir gehört dass feiern viele von
meinen freunden ich das riecht genauso
wie sind diese ganzen stars liegt ist es
das rot wie sie ist in die verpackung
grün wenn das innere die fahrbahn muss
ich das verstehen ich glaube ich jetzt
kommen wir zum besten von dem ganzen und
zwar den durstlöscher vier sich sechste
klasse pausenhof ich habe mir den
dingern gewählt also das kokain der
durstlöscher 40 kommt
denn das ding jetzt raus ohne scheiße zu
bauen
sehr gut ihren durstlöscher allemal
bitte in die kommentare schreiben
jetzt hofft er ja auch noch erzählt es
kommen wieder dünner cola
ich weiß auch nicht wie schmecken das
nimmt das raus aus dem laden wir haben
hier man guten loco houston monster
einer die juice das erhöhte der name
sagt schon dass das eigentlich nicht
sein kann ist eine schöne farbe sieht
auf die piste als nächstes kommen jetzt
so paula la spezia wiener kind planer
spät sie ist die beste spielt sie ich
weiß gar nicht was jetzt irgendwie was
über das sich jetzt reden soll
ich habe mädchen kennengelernt
das könnte ich sagen und wir ich fühle
mich ganz so als würde ich mit zum guten
homie reden uns jetzt schon ein paar mal
gesehen
ein paar mal spazieren und so läuft ganz
gut mal gucken heißt nämlich bereit bin
für eine beziehung
heute glaube aber dass wenigstens blau
das ist kein fan hoffe ich dass in
deutschland schnaps wenn es versagt
nee
das steuerlich kilmer hans kohler
wie kommen wir leben da es einfach mit
die schippe drauf sich auch direkt hier
weil vorher probiert jedoch wird er noch
geschliffen oder was die gelbe edition
red bull gut schmeckt aber scheiße wenn
diese leute in spa school fühlen so wenn
du sachen die man einfach machen kannst
kompliziert macht dann ist es das letzte
wofür man sich cool fühlen sollte in
seiner normalen auch so leute im
restaurant also auch gucken ob die hoch
von piero ich mit meinen dass das
endlich mal raus
das riecht villiger
[Applaus]
okay es ist okay gab ihnen mit back
davon aber auch noch ein bisschen rein
unsere komplette mischung hier ist jetzt
voll heldt wir haben eine ich zeige euch
das mal also das sieht aus wie meine
toilette nach dem indischen essen
mit einem schönen großen schluck du
kommst wieder hier vorne in und wir
vielleicht erst mal durchspielen müssen
egal kenne diese leute die sowas nur
diese leute die dann diesen wein dann
probleme machen jetzt versuchen wir
machen hier um den hier kommt mir jetzt
gerade ein bisschen die welt kaufen dann
im pressedienst zusammenzufassen
dieses komplette gemisch schmeckt zum
beispiel besser als diese döhnert oder
oder ist es monster aber deutlich
schlechter als jetzt beispielsweise wenn
ich als die vier sich mit der homebox
umgestellt was man an seiner stelle los
ich kann euch jetzt nur empfehlen mal
noch spotify zu gehen und dort die
konturen zu geben denn dort kamen heute
eine neue podcast folge online eine sehr
witzige episode meiner ansicht nach hört
sich auf jeden fall an und ich hab jetzt
diabetes